i think most programming languages are
designed for
cpus for single core even just in their
spirit
even if they allow for parallelization
so what does it look like for
programming language
to have um parallelization or massive
parallelization
as it's like first principle so
the canonical example of this is the
hardware design world
so verilog vhdl these kinds of languages
they're what's called a high-level
synthesis language
this is the thing people design chips in
and when you're designing a chip it's
kind of like a brain
where you have infinite parallelism like
you've got you're
you're like laying down transistors
transistors are always running
okay yeah and so you're not saying run
run this transistor then this transistor
is in this transistor
it's like your brain like your neurons
are always just doing something they're
not clocked
right there they're just they're just
doing they're they're doing their thing
and so when you design a chip or when
you design a cpu when you design a gpu
when you design when you're laying down
the transistors
uh similarly you're talking about well
okay well how do these things
communicate
and so these languages exist verilog is
um a
kind of mixed example of that none of
these languages are really great yeah
very low level yeah yeah they're very
low level and
abstraction is necessary here and
there's different different approaches
with that and
it's a it's itself a very complicated
world but um
but it's implicitly parallel and so
having
that as a as the domain that you program
towards
makes it so that by default you get
parallel systems if you look at cuda
kudo's a point
halfway in the space where in cuda when
you write a cuda kernel for your gpu
it feels like you're writing a scalar
program so you're like you have ifs you
have
for loops stuff like this you're just
writing normal normal code
but what happens outside of that in your
driver is that it actually is running
you on like
a thousand things at once right and so
it's it's parallel but it has pulled it
out of the programming model
and so now you as a programmer are
working at a uh
in a simpler world and it's solved that
for you
right how do you take the language like
swift
um you know if we think about gpus but
also asics
maybe if we can dance back and forth
between hardware and software
uh is you know how do you design for
these features to be able to
program make it a first class citizen to
be able to do
like swift for tensorflow to be able to
do machine learning
on current hardware but also future
hardware like uh
tpus and all kinds of asics that i'm
sure will be popping up more
yeah well so so a lot of this comes down
to this whole idea of having the nuts
and bolts underneath the covers that
work really well
so you need if you're talking to tpus
you need you know mlr or xla or one of
these compilers that talks to tpus
to build on top of okay and if you're
talking to circuits
you need to figure out how to lay down
the transistors and how to organize and
how to set up clocking and like all the
domain problems that you get with
circuits then you have to decide how to
explain to a human
what is the ui right and if you do it
right that's a library problem
not a language problem and that works if
you have a library
or a language which allows your library
writing to write things that feel native
in the language by implementing
libraries because then you can innovate
in
programming models without having to
change your syntax again
and like have to invent new code
formatting tools and like all the other
things that languages come with
and this this gets really interesting
and so
um if you look at the space the
interesting thing once you separate out
syntax becomes what is that programming
model
and so do you want the cuda style i
write one program and it runs
many places the um do you want the
implicitly parallel model how do you
reason about that how do you give
developers you know chip architects the
the ability to express their intent and
that comes into
this whole design question of how do you
detect bugs
quickly so you don't have to tape out a
chip to find out it's wrong
ideally right how do you and and you
know this is a spectrum
how do you make it so that people feel
productive so their turnaround time is
very quick
all these things are really hard
problems and um
in this world i think that not a lot of
effort has been put into that
design problem and thinking about the
layering in other pieces
you